politique toujours l'actualité pour le
gouvernement pour les socialistes
aujourd'hui c'est la publication du
patrimoine des ministres à 19 heures
auparavant annoncé à 17 heures l'horaire
a finalement été décalée je vous
rappelle qu'il est 18 heures passées de
quelques minutes si vous nous suivez en
direct
nous devrions découvrir ce patrimoine
dans les prochaines minutes dans les
yvelines benoît hamon ministre déléguée
à la solidarité élue députée en juin
dernier dans la 11e circonscription
devrait déclaré posséder un appartement
encore une voiture où il n'épargne
avoisinant les 20 mille euros plus de
précision je vous le disais dans les
prochaines heures nous avons contacté
benoît hamon aujourd'hui ne souhaite
faire aucun commentaire ni sur cette
déclaration elle ni sur le choix de
françois hollande de rendre public le
patrimoine des élus
il y a quelques jours il s'était montré
plutôt mesurée en déclarant on ne fera
jamais une loi qui supprime le un
mensonge
prochaine étape dans cette opération de
transparence politique la présentation
le 24 avril d'un projet de loi de
moralisation et ce grand déballage campo
celle où nous sommes allés vous posez la
question réponse au micro d' elodie
moines se changera rien
saoulé que ça change dans la vie des
gens rien
non c est aller ça arrive je vois pas
l'intérêt ils vont pêcher
ils vous donneront pas la valeur réelle
des de ce qu'ils ont par exemple ils ont
un appartement n'importe quoi s'il coûte
600 milles il va le donner pour 300
milles sur sa tenue en appréciant sa
façon d'être dans une cour d'école
donc c'est un peu
voilà je trouve ça très très bête
après c'est leur vie c'est pas la nôtre
on va pas qu'ils n'ont tout le monde
déballe sa vie pourquoi pas après tout
on est en droit de connaître le la
fortune et la fortune de nos élus on va
y en a peut-être qui vont triché au 6ème
enfin bon ça sera peut-être un peu plus
difficile maintenant de tricher en tout
cas je l'espère